So what I'd like to do is actually step
through a concrete counterexample that
really does show that a particular
way of doing this kind of training
can fail in the worst case and this
is an example due to Lehman Baird and
it's devious and clever.
>> Hm, I like devious and clever.
>> So here's a really simple MDP.
You ready?
It's got six states and
then a seventh absorbing state.
>> Okay.
>> For each state,
there's exactly one action.
There's no stochasticity.
There's no rewards of any kind.
They're all zero.
So this is a really simple example,
right?
>> Sure,
that seems pretty straightforward.
>> All right, so then what is the
optimal value function and policy for
this example?
>> The optimal value function or
optimal policy?
>> I asked for both.
>> There is no optimal policy,
it doesn't matter what you do.
You just have to do one thing.
>> There's only one policy and
it is optimal by definition of optimal.
>> In the value function, the proper
value function would be zero everywhere.
>> Zero's everywhere, right,
because there's no
>> Rewards anywhere.
So right so
this is super duper simple and
if we had to learn this
using Q learning or
something like that presumably this
would actually learn quite quickly.
What we're going to do though
to make life difficult
is we're going to do this in
a function approximation setting,
linear function approximation with
this following set of features.
So, there's there's the seven states
in the picture and associated with each
state is a feature vector and there's
eight features that are part of that.
Feature zero one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, feature zero
is one for all the states and seven for
this for the repeating state.
And interestingly, we have it set up so
that these other features are actually
completely indicative of which states
you're in, so
state one has feature one being true.
State two has feature two being true.
State three has feature
three being true.
Or at least.
[LAUGH] And by true I mean two.
I guess.
>> Two.
Yeah.
>> And so
that's kind of the representation here.
So state six looks like one.
And then zeros is everywhere.
Except for feature six which has a 2 and
then a 0, right?
So this feature representation is
actually really close to being
just a table.
>> Yeah.
>> So I'm going to say near tabular
in the sense that if we get rid of
this first feature there's going to be
one weight that represents the value for
state one and one weight that
represents a value for state two and so
forth and one weight that represent
the value for state seven and so
it's exactly just a table.
One weight or one table entry per state.
>> All right.
>> And all we've done is kind of made it
a little bit more by having this extra
feature that we ought to be
able to just ignore, right.
And we should be able to
represent things pretty well.
So in fact,
I think that it's worth asking.
Can we represent the optimal
value function using this
set of weights right?
So if our parameters are W0 through W7,
is there a way to set them so
that the value function that we get is
the actual value function for this MDP?
>> Sure there is one easy one.
>> And what's that?
>> Set them all to zero.
>> Right.